it's just saying like you're saying you
got called fat when you were younger so
now you're going to call someone else
about to try and make them feel bad I
feel like that I'm just like it's not to
make them it's not no no it's not to
make them feel bad or you know maybe
maybe they should feel bad enough to get
on the treadmill and run yeah
that's what I did I look at Luke I swear
to God I had I had 200 pounds you know
what I hit 200 pounds it was the worst
day of my life and some dude at work
like they're saying oh I would never
date a girl over 200 pounds and I and I
and I carry the weight better so like
I'm taller right so I don't think he
knew I was and
and so I signed up for a marathon I
swear to God I ran a marathon then I
lost their life and I lost a bunch of
weight what so you signed up bro because
because I'm not lazy because I was like
oh [__] this is a problem and if you
know what we do instead we say you're
not a whale you look great you're not
fat even though that's it is what it is
and you deserve love that's the worst
one everyone deserves love no one
deserves
you don't think you deserve all right
you earn it you don't deserve it in life
what do you think men deserve then if if
they still deserve love everyone
what is the guy what is the guy that
approached you what does he deserve love
but you know why didn't you give it to
him I said to him I said to him I said
to him because baby he's not for me I
said to him in my dad's accent as well
so funny I said to him so many times in
the nicest way listen bro I'm not
interested I have a boyfriend you seem
like you're a nice person I'm not
interested yet please leave me alone if
you say that to someone a few times and
they're still not getting it do you know
what wait do you hear that it's the
world's small smallest
[Laughter]
the guy is running with you
let's not tell you that I like you he's
54. how many guys are wrong dude that's
even more impressive a 54 dude running
with you in the morning running with you
my dude's putting in shifts listen
where's the love that's that's
borderline abuse like if a 54 year old
was jogging with me just to say yo you
look good bro even if this gay guy is
doing that thank you my dude thank you
do you think you have pretty privilege
I think all women to an extent have
pretty privilege yes
yeah yeah do you think do you think
whales have pretty privilege
Welles are cute you think you think
whales is a very nice do you think
whales have the same amount of pretty
privilege that you have as in the ones
in the ocean is that what we're talking
about no I'm talking about fat chicks no
I'm not talking I'm not calling them
that okay
what do women wears let's just stop that
okay fat chicks no big women bigger
bigger women I'm not why can't I call
them what they are you guys I'm saying
like why do you want to live in delusion
they have more fat
I'll tell you why you got a little
delusion it minimizes accountability you
can be offended and it can be plausible
at the same time or it can be
accomplishment I feel like I feel like
you can carry weight in completely
different way and it will look different
on different people like there's guys
right like it's like you said you're
tall who looks
200 pounds on you and you still didn't
look like you were that big no I was
kind of Wheeling it so how much does
your boyfriend weigh when people in this
world this whole plus size thing is like
why don't you marry a plus-sized person
he's like 96 kg I don't know what KGS I
don't know what pounds is you were
saying 200 I was like I don't know what
that is 13 stone kind of thing yeah
what's that so that makes it weighs more
than you yeah he weighs more than me
he's a bigger guy
so that goes to that goes to show what
I'm saying what that
um
uh fat women that you don't like to hear
look at the Celeb I'm gonna say let's go
uh girlfriend
I think it depends on it doesn't work
I'm gonna characterize as fat
because if we're talking if we're
talking about fat yeah three is a load
of girls 300 fat asses and you'd be like
yeah 300. where's the fat is it in the
booty name one girl that looks good at
300 pounds I know what 300 pounds is the
word obese you know what 300 pounds is
you know what a fat girl is yeah what is
that in stone
300.
pounds what is that like is that over
15.
oh it's 21 Stone 21st yeah name one girl
that looks good at 21 Stone
that's not a whale I don't know anyone
at 21 Stone so in media I can think of a
lot of plus size models I don't know
does lizard look good because you never
know I think she's cute personally I
think she's cute
do you think most men want to screw her
I don't know what most men do you think
do you think she gets the same pretty
privilege you do
I don't know I don't know I think you do
know you do know I think I think I think
if you were sat next to you when your
boyfriend introduced himself to you I
think you would have felt pretty
confident
sister right so I had this message
growing up she's actually way she used
to bully me for a bit because I was like
a hippie nice guy when I was growing up
I was like no State there's no ego
whatever but um I I had the privilege of
actually hearing what women actually
think like women women don't say the
truth on purpose when they get together
when they talk with each other that's
when they say the truth that's then they
say why they get with this guy what they
like about that guy do you do you think
you want to keep them fat so you don't
have to compete with them
like subconsciously yeah the other girls
right because with who though like why
you don't think you got competition yeah
you think you have no competition I
don't want to compete with like why am I
competing with them anyway like it's not
like it's not life or death you know you
don't think you have to compete for a
man not really that's a privilege okay
well I'll take that but if there's less
wills it might not be awarded to you no
because just as I said just lucky for
you lucky for you there's a lot of girls
Plumping themselves up right now so just
being in shape you're like I like a
juicy girl look it look it you're in the
top like 30 just not being fat
there's nothing wrong with a girl that's
got a bit of back like it's fine no it's
just yeah there's nothing wrong yeah
there's nothing wrong with a girl I
think it's not the back I think it's
like the gut the armpit fat
eyes you know when they got like the
little bag on the stomach like the
the the human beanbag on their stomach
that's messed up man
like for me like when people normalize
this it's just like it's not healthy
they're gonna die young yeah that's not
good like I don't know why people are
like letting them die I had a woman come
on that say obesity is suicide yeah
obesity suicide
so like but I'm not forcing someone to
be fat right but you're but you're
saying it's a beer you're supporting
yeah
you're normalizing it I'm not I care
about them enough to call them a whale
to motivate them to save their life I I
should be a hero right now
I give her a whale ribbon right now I'm
I'm motivating them to get on the
treadmill look at it if you love someone
you tell them the truth
I think Society has kind of dumbed
things down and made it so that
everything is okay do you do whatever
you want but trying to eliminate the
consequences but how like how is not
being able to walk okay yeah it's not
okay at all diabetes
but it's still a way we should diabetes
we should multiple because for example I
run a football Academy right and there
are people if they are overweight the
way I would approach it I wouldn't
immediately say you know you're fat no I
would take them and then I'll I will
show them that you're overweight I'll
clearly explain it but it won't hold on
but it won't be a case of me because
obviously it's not gonna it's gonna
demotivate my demand yeah exactly what I
would do is I will show them the truth
but I will also give them a way to
change that so but obviously the thing
that's wrong with Society right now is
that we're saying oh it's okay for you
to just be like that and keep doing what
you're doing and you deserve love
yeah okay
why does someone else have to deal with
your problems because you're gonna have
so many health issues and now who's
gonna take care of you the guy that's in
shape the thinner partner
and then you're saying they deserve they
deserve to be taking like what do you do
in your old age oh my gosh they have to
deal with like how are you gonna push
them around in a wheelchair when they're
300 pounds
[Laughter]
if you've got a fat friend you're
telling you need to go lose weight you
have to tell him
yeah okay and the fat kids that were
bullied they lost weight and now they're
healthier not all of them oh well the
one what about the ones that like took
it to heart and then
those ones shouldn't reproduce right but
the ones the ones the ones that did the
ones that were like oh wow maybe I am
fat and actually made a change and
actually improved their diet improve
their health those those are the ones
that are better for it and they're
stronger individuals mentally but my
theory is I don't think women actually
want that to happen I think I think that
they kind of subconsciously want to
destroy people and each other so I think
they would rather tell each other that
they all look good because I don't think
you really want the best for each other
I don't I don't think like women sitting
with their fat friend telling her that
oh yeah someone's Really Gonna Love You
for you and like you deserve this and
that instead of telling her what she
needs to know because I know a lot of
women like this and they can lie all day
you know what but there that I feel and
this is the point that I've been like
this is what I've been saying to myself
in my head I feel like there seems to be
like a lot of like toxic behavioral
traits that are involved in these
situations that you're playing now and
this is where I said like I grew up
different I love my friends we all look
completely different there are people
that are bigger there are people yeah
guilt and need to be right you're
shaming him what do you mean did you
have a fat friend toxic traits
but I'm not
saying that you don't
and so I'm saying like this is like
Narrows that he's coming up with as in
saying that like oh I was fat and I was
bullied like that's a toxic scenario